so now that you know what you're
expecting to change through your
hypothesis and what you're going to do
you need to run an experiment you can do
this using an a/b test this will help
you compare two different versions of
your webpage or app and learn which one
performs better you can use a control
group in an experimental group having a
control group can show you how effective
your campaign is now the control group
consists of randomly selected users who
are representative of the population
you're targeting and who do not receive
the change to whatever campaign you're
running so being representative of the
population means that if 50% of your app
users are male and 50% are female you
need to have the same demographic in
your randomly selected control group
now everything except the one change
your targeting should stay the same for
example if you want to test the effect
of moving your signup button to the top
of the screen all messaging colors looks
and feel of the site should stay the
same except for moving the signup button
to the top of the screen and only the
people in the experimental group will
see these changes so the people in the
experimental group will see the signup
button at the top of the page and the
people in the control group won't see a
change in the location of the signup
button this way you can see how the
people in the two different groups
perform in which button placement would
result in more signups now your control
group doesn't need to be huge the key is
that it's representative of the target
population if you have a really really
large population like thousands and
thousands of people you might only need
about five percent of that population to
be in your control group however if it's
a smaller population you may need closer
to 20% to be in your control group to
determine the best sample size for your
experiment there are a ton of free
online sample size calculators you can
check out now to run a b tests or ton of
different tools that you can use for
example Optimizely allows you to make
changes on your website and will run and
host the experiment for you so let's
hear from an expert about a/b testing